hey what's up guys my name's samuel
leeds welcome to another
winners on a wednesday every single week
i interview one of my success students
who've become financially
independent financially free as a direct
result
of our property investment training this
week i have with me anthony wilmot who
has become not just financially free but
he's making crazy money
he made over 200 000 pound over a
six-month period
of packaging and selling deals he's
working on some seven
figure development deals and he's i mean
i mean anthony you have done
so many deals over the last couple few
years it's just i mean i always say
you came on the crash course um i
mentored you you came on the academy
now if i'm stuck i'll call you that's
how experience you've become this
actually
happened right the way back in 2018 now
uh
january 2018 i was working as a retail
manager for sainsbury's
and i got told i was potentially in a
position of being made redundant from my
job
and i didn't really know what to do with
myself at that point
and i remember reaching out to my
brother who was an electrician
at the time and saying like you know
maybe i can
come and work with you maybe i can train
to be an electrician maybe i can get
into a trade you know i didn't really
know
what was next for me you know knocking
on over 30 and i don't really know what
i'm going to do
and he said to me said that's great you
can come and work with me
but actually long term we're looking to
get into property
and i was like sounds amazing but i can
barely keep the roof over my head
let alone buy another house what am i
gonna do
and i remember him putting me in touch
with some of your videos and i thought
who is this absolutely crazy guy that
i'm watching these videos of
this isn't really for me and the more
and more i delved into it i
came to the crash course and it
completely opened my eyes and i was
going to these free events
the crash course and some all the
networking events i was like
this is really achievable this is doable
even if now i'm coming from a position
with no money um
you know it is doable you know if you
can network and if you can
make the right connections and really it
just spiraled from there i remember
coming to the crash course and i did
everything in my power to raise money to
come to your advanced training
even crashed my car on the way to the
deal finding extravaganza but
nothing was going to stop me from
pushing forward for this i'd made a
commitment to myself that was going to
get into property
you know i could see the value i could
provide to other people i could see
the position i'd come from where within
rented accommodation and how i now
wanted to
to provide great houses for people and i
was really making that my
mission and ever since then i've
literally i've gone at it
100 mile an hour and i've looked back
and it's funny because
i mean you said as well at the crash
course you said to your brother you're
like
do you remember at the crash course yeah
um oh i said at the crash course i said
i the thing that got me was i remember
sitting at the crash course and i'd
watch some of these events and then i
was like i was expecting a video to come
on and you to pop on on this video and
then somebody to be hosting the event
and you walked out and i was like oh my
god like he's actually here he took the
time to come out
and teach us this i said i'm gonna be
friends with that guy
said i'm gonna be friends with that guy
and that's one of the one of the
missions i made and you know like like
you said we ring each other up now we
have conversations and
you know we're friends and and that i
i didn't think i'd get one of my goals
to come true but it's about pushing
forward isn't it and the reason we did
become friends though was because
i mean for me i pay attention to people
get on my radar by taking massive action
and i saw you at the crash course you
had no money
not in a great place at all in lots of
different areas of your life
and and you know you kind of hit rock
bottom really
and but it wasn't the end
you know you were like this is gonna
change i'm gonna and you signed up for
the deal finally extravaganza i don't
know how you afforded it how did you how
did you get the money for that so i
actually put it on my credit card
at the time yeah um because i paid for
myself for my brother i put it on my
credit card and i was like don't worry
i've got this we'll sort it out we'll be
fine
um and so coming to that event was it
was life-changing because
networking with the people that were
there and even just the first 10 minutes
of that event you know
at these at these you know advanced
courses one of the first things you'd do
at
the deal finance extravaganza was so
what's your strategy what you're looking
to do next and i remember being
always first to put my hand up and
you're like yeah go ahead watch your
strategy and i told you and you went
stupid and you were like that strategy
is daft because you're never going to
get to where you want to get to because
you're looking at a long-term strategy
when you don't have finance now so you
need to start focusing on things like
rent to rent you need to start focusing
on things like deal sourcing
bring in the money gain the knowledge
and then once you've done that then you
can start focusing on your long-term
goals which is build a wealthy portfolio
do these biorefurbish refinances and
that light bulb moment is is what then
gave me
the motivation to go on and think well
actually yeah it just makes sense that's
the way i should pivot it
it's so powerful you say i i didn't
actually remember that until you just
said
but yeah because you were talking about
i want to build a buy to let portfolio
i want to do get them to do development
deals and i said forget that
just become financially free just become
fine and when you become financially
free and you've got
an income coming in from rental events
or whatever or you deal sourcing you can
you can live in your full-time property
ftp ffuff mission right
when you go through the steps then start
building that up and go on to bigger
deals and we're going to get to that
because now you're working on some
crazy big deals which are just so
inspiring even for me i'm inspired
um but okay so what happened next you
came to the deal finding extravaganza
you crashed your car you you seemed like
such a sorry person
you get there no money honestly you
couldn't even make it off i was
i'd come down there and laurie
sideswiped me on the way
and i pulled over and uh i found my mum
i was like mom i need to get to this
training
like i don't even care about the car and
i'll just come and get me and so she
dropped me off and i still turned up on
time i still
i still was there committed 110 because
you know i paid this training i was
going to get the most out of it
from that i you know i went on to the
academy because i had to get involved
with that i had to get in you know just
the network
every time you go up these levels of
people that have invested in themselves
you see a change in mentality yeah you
know i love the free course i love free
networking events i love stuff like that
they're a great
eye opener for people but when you see
people that have invested money into
their education
or invested into the people around them
their mindset changes and i wanted to be
around them people
i wanted to be around the people that
had invested you know and i wanted to be
one of them as well
and so coming onto the academy i started
to go into some of the training
and i was always there i was always the
first person at the front and i think
that
i think that was one of the reasons why
you guys invited me to become part of
the eviction
you know and that that was a great
experience because this is exactly why
because you're always on the front row
you were passionate
we knew that you didn't have i mean i
mean jeez i hate to say this but you put
the deal financed over guns on your
credit card
you then join the academy how did you
pay for the academy so i actually got a
loan out for the academy believe it or
not and you know what's really
interesting about that
okay you had you know like i don't
remember saying this but you have mental
health issues
you know some serious stuff going on
you're in debt
we we could have very easily turned you
away and gone you know what this isn't
for you you can't afford it you're not
in a good place very easily
but we didn't and now as a result
you're financially free completely
like one of the most successful people
on our academy which is just crazy is it
not
thank you i think the thing is you know
at the time i made a decision obviously
i i wasn't i wasn't poor i wasn't in in
hundreds of thousand pounds of debt
you know i didn't have you know loads of
money to my name i had
the money that was coming in month by
month on a wage basis but i was like i'm
gonna do this and
can i financially afford to put myself
in this situation yeah you know
to go ahead with it and you know it was
a tough commitment to make because
to take out a loan to do something like
the academy
is scary you know because and but again
you know that pain of doing that is what
drove me to to push forward
and you know from the point of doing the
deal finding extravaganza
in that very short space of time you
know um
i did the deal fine extravaganza
september
and by the end of october we got our
first rent to rent deal
and we'd also sourced our first deal as
well you know so
it just goes to show that it can be done
if you put the effort in yeah
um and then obviously when we went into
2019 you know we were just pushing
forward again
even more because we just wanted to we
you know i just wanted to put the effort
in and i wanted to make this happen
yeah and i didn't want to go back to
sainsbury's you know i loved the job
but i just didn't feel valued there
anymore you know and i
i wanted to make something i wanted to
make a legacy for myself and for my
family
i think it just goes to show for me and
from my point of view you know because
people sometimes say to me
you know you should be more you should
you should be more choosy about who you
accept onto your training
and for me i've i've spent so many
hundreds of hours weighing up
that comment but it's impossible to know
who's going to be successful and who's
not sometimes we have doctors
that that come to the crash course and
they've got loads of money and then a
year later i check in with them and
they've done
nothing and then other time we have
people come on that have got nothing
and they might seem like like me when i
started i was working class
teenager with nothing going to these
events
people could have very easily turned me
away at the door do you know what i'm
saying
judge the way i look at it is
education is always an investment you
know i've got a degree in business
management
and i've got a pgce so i'm a qualified
teacher
and i use neither of them and they cost
me a lot of money to do both of them
and my i i did my pgce to become a
teacher
and then no sooner did i finish it i
decided that
teaching wasn't for me and it was going
to have too much strain and too much
impact on my mental health
so all of that money i put into that
that was a lot of money to do that
course all of that money
put into that and i had nothing to show
for it yeah and
it's not because the education was bad
because the education was amazing
you know and i made some lasting
relationships there but
it's just about you've got to look at
you you've got to put the effort in of
where you want to go and sometimes it
costs and sometimes it doesn't yeah
and you and for me i mean you made the
choice
no one told you to go and get a loan no
no one told you to put something on your
credit card
all we did was tell you how much it cost
and then you made that decision and you
put the effort and you made it work
i remember saying to you i remember
setting you a challenge and saying
you got to view 40 houses in the next
month
or was it two weeks it was two weeks two
weeks and if you do i'll give you a
grand cash to fix your car
yeah and then when when you didn't do it
you were just shy i think you got 36
hours 36 yeah i was actually like well i
saved myself a grand
but i don't care if you're gonna if i'm
gonna have to give you a grind or not
what i care about is if you try and view
40 even if you do 36 or even if you do
26
you're gonna make more money than a
grand as a result because you're gonna
well what happened well that's how we've
secured our first deal so
i viewed 36 houses um i could have gone
for the 40 but
we'd secured a deal and i wanted to
focus on selling that deal you know
that's the whole plan it's not about
just winning a bet
although i enjoyed the bet and then
we co-sourced and we sold that deal
because i didn't have my list of
investors so again it's all about
networking with the people around you
um i made a thousand pound from that
deal so i made the same amount of money
yeah but that then i built network with
people yeah um so you didn't need my
thousand pounds because you made a
thousand just by viewing the houses
so so you always someone i knew was
going to go far
i actually did harass you a bit into
joining the academy if i remember
because you did the deal finding
extravaganza
i made you the bet you went and made a
grand which was like amazing and then i
think you sold another deal and then you
sold another day i was like
dude you need to come on the academy
like you need
to come on the academy your plan is
terrible this whole buy to let stuff
just come
on the academy i didn't know what your
financial situation was but you then
joined i think january 2018 it was
january 2019 yeah 2009 started your
academy yeah
and um what happened then so started the
academy
obviously started to build relationship
with people so this is when i met james
james and i obviously straight away
really bounced very well off one another
you know we started looking at deals
together um
funnily enough we started to look at a
commercial to residential project back
then in
in january that is round the corner from
the one that we're now buying wow um
it didn't pan out and it didn't go
anywhere but it showed us how we could
work together
um you know we we got builders on site
we went through the process with
planners with architects so it's
we started to get familiar with the
process um and then obviously
april you know i got asked to be part of
the eviction so then then things
really stepped up a stage then yeah um
and then
after winning the eviction things just
just blew off i just have to say so
sorry
you won the eviction you were only a big
[ __ ] yeah so
there was there was about i think 12
people on that there was a month of your
life
that was just an incredible month
the crazy thing about the eviction was i
um i'd agreed to buy a new house and i
moved into my house two days before
coming onto the eviction
so i moved in and gave the key to my
partner i said i'll see you in a month
because i am winning when i come back
yeah if anyone doesn't know about the
evictions you might have just seen it on
youtube but
a bunch of people living in a house or a
castle i think we were actually
we were in a castle together that month
and uh every
challenge that we finish someone gets
evicted until there's the winner
you and hannah were in the finalists and
um you won
which which the prize that year was 20
000 pounds hard cash
what did you do with the 20 grand that's
what i want to know so i've actually
used that
to invest in some of the strategies
we're doing now so it's gone on some of
the soft costs of planning into some of
the projects we've done
we actually secured five lease option
apartments uh whilst we were on the
eviction
uh so what they saw on the tv when they
saw you
going and securing five lease options
from scratch
you actually kept them we actually kept
them we took them on um
we rented them out as service
departments and then we had
an agreement to take them on as lease
options so we put some money in towards
doing some renovations on them as well
i actually as i said moved out of my
previous houses some of the money went
to refurb that so that became a buyer
refurbishing finance project
so i actually kept that house and now
rent it out to tenants yeah
um that yeah you just did so much in
2010.
so much like tell me about the
highlights of 2019. so 2019
i'd obviously had my first service
department in sheffield we secured three
more
in sheffield so i ended up with four
service departments we got the five
lease option apartments
and then i've got my two by refurbishing
finance houses as well which we've got
um we also agreed the sale on a
commercial to residential project in
2019
so this is an old pub that we're going
to turn into six apartments
so this is a joint venture with james
armstrong
and this was the first real taster we
got from commercial to residential
um in 2019 as well we actually came
across
uh what i keep calling to you the secret
project so it's a commercial
to residential grade two listed building
that is gonna be
absolutely phenomenal and like i keep
saying to you once you've got planning
through i'm going to take you there
james and i want to give you the full
tour presentation and i know your jaw
will hit the floor
i can't wait to see it and and i mean it
really is the secret
project because i have no idea what it
is anthony you've not told me a thing
all you keep telling me is how much
money you're going to make which is
all i'll say is in the seven figures
right so
ridiculously exciting you're supposed to
hopefully be complete on that pretty
pretty soon yeah so we should be
completing january um
this year yeah this end of this month
and it's taken so long for us to get
into this situation so all these great
things that happened
in in 20 2019 like you said over that
period of time from where
we left the eviction as well we actually
made over two hundred thousand pound a
deal source
that's incredible so we were working i
was in a six month period as well
we were grafting hard you know we were
working really hard
um and of them projects as well we do
we've project managed
some so we've actually managed refurbs
for our investors along the way as well
and
and you know you would see on my channel
on my facebook and things where we
document this journey just to show
people what we're doing you show people
it's possible
look i just say that again 200 pounds
two hundred thousand pounds yeah from
july 2019 was it
until january 2020 may so after we
literally as soon as we finished the
eviction we just went like six seven
months
yeah incredible now you slipped then
because i used to always say to you
don't worry about building wealth until
firstly you make first you've got to
make money
then you've got to invest money then
you've got to preserve money so
i say to you right from the beginning
just make money right focus on making
money what's going to make you money
you remember this then you start
investing money you know and now you're
going under some of these much much
bigger deals
and in fact as well talk to me about
because i know that some of your
lease option agreements like those five
lease option agreements you made the
commercial decision
very recently to give those back to the
owner and not go ahead with them which
some people would see as a failure
and say oh they failed then but you
don't really see it like that so
talk to me about that so when 2020
kicked in
obviously we've got these two commercial
to residential projects and i was like i
don't want to take anything else on i
need to slow down
and then coronavirus kicked in and we
could see the
impending change of the market and where
our lease option apartments were
we'd obviously like you always teach
don't take on a lease option if you have
no intention to buy it
yeah you know we wanted to stick to that
because we wanted to be honorable to the
landlords and to you know
about what we wanted to do so we could
see the impending change
of the market so we went to the
landlords to renegotiate the lease
option terms
we had every intention of purchasing
them but we needed to change the terms
of the contract
yeah sure to make it financially
beneficial to them and to us because the
cash flow wasn't quite where we wanted
it yeah
now unfortunately they didn't want to
negotiate the contract
so you know like you said we made the
business decision to step away from it
because
even though we had another couple of
years left on our lease such an
agreement
we we knew we weren't going to purchase
them and we didn't want to make the
money
and benefit from the cash flow over the
next coming years and promise them to
buy them
when we had no intentions of course of
course and i think that that
i mean for me and i'd love to get your
your input on this
people are sometimes so scared to take
on a lease option agreement in case it
doesn't work out but the thing is if it
doesn't work out
panic he's back like did you lose money
on those deals we didn't lose money no
no you might not have made a great deal
either but it's it's not it's not
it's not a bad thing sometimes things
don't go to plan same as your your
your pub i mean i make jokes about it
because every time i ask you when it's
going to complete you say
it's supposed to be next week like and
that's been going on for now almost a
year
but this is the nature of property well
this
is it and you know 2020 has been very
challenging on many fronts so
the pub uh has been one of our deals
that this has happened to but some of
the ones we've been managing for
investors
you know we've had to change our whole
financing strategy and change our whole
purchasing perspective
sure because of the impact of
coronavirus and
so this uh material uncertainty clause
that they brought in
it stopped our ability to obtain lending
so we should have completed on the pub
january 20 2020 and now we're due to
complete on it
january 2021 this year um and that's all
because of the way lending's changed
we've had to raise additional finance
for it we've had to completely change
the structure of how we're purchasing it
yeah but it's about adapting to the
changes in the market and
dropping these five lease option
apartments was just that
adapting to the changes in the market
yeah and you know
our rent to essays in sheffield we made
the same decision with them we had four
we decided to drop two yeah because they
just weren't doing what we wanted to do
and
the landlord was great and would give us
uh he you know he's happy to give us
um rent holidays on the properties and
and work with us and negotiate but the
market just isn't coming back in the
area where these apartments are
yeah so we decided rather we would you
know have an agreement with the landlord
where we would let him keep all the
furniture so
it makes it beneficial to him we
actually help them find a long-term
tenant for the properties as well yeah
relationships exactly so if you've so
with you basically with you with your
portfolio
i mean obviously the properties that you
own you buy refurbished finance deals
great cool kept them yep nice and
healthy but with the ones that you were
controlling
um you you got rid of some you kept some
i mean you two you've still got two
rental rents are they making money yeah
they still make good money yeah so
they're actually located in the city
centre of sheffield
so throughout the pandemic we've had
when when all the lockdown finished and
things started to peak back up we were
getting daily tenants coming people
coming on staycations
as things have come into the tier system
again uh we've got long term tenants
there so we're actually booked
right now with them yes um we've got
long term tenants which is great right
the way through the new year we had
long-term tenants
so we're not really worried about them
because we know as we go into this year
they're positioned right
and that's why we kept them that was the
right business decision for us
yeah you've grown so fast and you've
grown so big
but i feel that you've done it in the
right way because you've not massively
over leveraged
i know you've raised a lot of money but
you've also made a lot of money how much
how much money did you raise last year
so in 2020 we've raised just over a
million pound in investor finance that's
incredible
and it's because we decided to pivot our
strategy
yeah so um there's going to be a lot of
changes with planning regulations
and permitted development so we've
decided to change our strategy to more
commercial conversions and development
and you know so we've spent the whole of
the year i spent the whole
of of 2020 focusing on finding land
deals finding development projects
we've actually sourced six throughout
the period most of these we found
through lockdown as well
um you know when we found some some
great commercial to residential and some
great land projects
that we're going to be pushing forward
in this year yeah
so and you've got a one a piece of land
you're
going to be building 24 houses on it 14.
oh sorry 14. yeah that was that that's
your next deal right
that's the next one that's the next one
we'll be building we'll be building 50
before you know it yeah but still 14
houses dude that's incredible
but this is a great plot and um where is
it where was it so this one's in in the
northwest
yeah and we we're joint venturing this
with james armstrong and david taylor
so david taylor actually did all the
initial appraisal on the land of this
site a long time ago
and now the vendor's selling it we're
going to be taking the site on and
developing
ourselves so i'm really excited but
again these relationships have come
from the academy and i'm excited to take
this journey with them and and
it's going to be great so we know that
this is going to be a great unit and
the the one thing i like particularly
about this site that we're buying at the
minute why we've got loads of confidence
with it and we raise the money like that
is because across the road adjacent to
where our site is
is a development that's just gone on
with i think it's
40 houses that's been built on there 34
something like i can't remember the
exact number but that when we're looking
at developments is exactly what we want
to see
yeah because when somebody's developing
somewhere one of these big builders
um you know then we know that if we pick
up a smaller site
it's exactly what we want yeah yeah yeah
and you know what development is
obviously something that we don't talk
much about
too much publicly i don't do loads on my
youtube about it because
it it comes with risks
if you don't know what you're doing it's
the same as like auctions and
when you're doing this sort of deal
packaging and selling deals or doing a
rental rental if it doesn't work out you
just hand the keys back
offering to buy a piece of land to build
20 houses or 14 houses
you know you really really need to know
what you're doing and
i always advise and i advise this to you
i advise this i was saying yesterday i
was talking to a guy who was saying to
me
you know i've got 1.3 million pounds i
want to invest it i want to do a big
development deal and i say look keep 1.2
let's play with a hundred grand let's do
a little brr deal to get your confidence
up because i know if i'm working with
him on his on a million pound deal he'll
be a nervous wreck
and i think one of the great things that
i've seen about you over the last couple
years
well almost a few years now is is your
growth journey
you know you started off you came to me
with nothing
you know and you've grown to the point
now where you're doing deals
that are massive you know really really
big deals and you've grown into that
you've made money from deal source and
you became financially free from your
rental rents you've got your lease
options which you've now given back
unfortunately but whatever
but just the journey it's the perfect
example of of of the progression
on the property journey i mean what
would be your biggest advice
if you you know if you're advising
someone that's you three years ago
you know what would be your best advice
to get started honestly i think
my best advice is always the advice i
give to people is about networking
um you know the academy and the people
around me are the reason why i am where
i am now
and 2020 has been such a difficult year
for most people me included
and a lot of i become part of an
accountability group with
some of the people on the academy and
you know they'll be watching this video
and they know who they are
and then people helped me through where
i am now yeah you know we keep each
other accountable and we help each other
push forward
and i think if you haven't got that
network of people around you
then who is there to keep you
accountable because when things get
tough you'll just go back to sitting
watching tv you won't keep yourself
accountable so
true and you know what the academy i
mean the academy is so much more than
than samuel leeds you know yes i
started it created it but but the the
environment and the people on the
academy it's just something
absolutely you can't even explain it you
know and the crash courses as well
i think you can probably more than
anyone hand on heart site it all starts
at the crash course
it does and you know what was absolutely
amazing to watch recently i mean i love
coming to crash course and i love my
you know five minutes of fame or 20
minutes of fame or whatever it is to
time to get on stage but
it was so humbling to watch the virtual
crash course
and see some of the academy members
talking about their journeys and
and you kind of sit there and think oh
my god i remember having a conversation
with you about that and it's great to
see that now you're growing and
just seeing everybody's journey and then
watching some of the people that you
pull out at the crash course
and then thinking if you continue on
that path and you continue on that
journey in 12 months time
we'll be sat there watching you telling
everybody about your journey yeah and
that's the thing
and it's really interesting as well i
want to talk a little bit about your
journey as well because we have
got you involved in um some of the
trainings i pull you up on stage quite a
lot and now you do
you know you you do give back an awful
lot to the academy
you you know you came to the academy
initially to to learn how to become
financially free
but now okay fine i'm sure you get a lot
from the academy still now but now you
give so much to the academy i mean
when you speak to all of our academy
members like what's the best thing about
the academy anthony
john is the best thing about the academy
like you know because you just spend
so much time you don't have to but just
adding value
sitting with people talking with people
mentoring people sharing your
experiences taking people on
on sites and um you know i want to talk
a little bit about
why you do that because i think it's
interesting
who you hang around with rubs off on you
and people sometimes don't understand
sam you should make so much money
training sorry if not if you make so
much money i don't make any money from
training as you know
make a penny if you make so much money
in property why do you bother training
you know what why do you do that and
and it's like you know what because it's
it's so damn rewarding
you know it's and i think anyone that
does training
for the money because they think i
better make some money training you're
not gonna
it's just not gonna work out because
it's it's a hard
industry it is it's hard mentoring
people it's hard
it is it is and the thing is the money
that you pay
to get into the training is a reflection
of the effort that the trainer puts in
for you yeah you know and the one of the
reasons why i love
helping people is because when i started
it was so hard for me to find the
information
without paying 25 30 000
for training it you know it was a lot
some of the people that
that i was going to at the time and you
know
i knew i was missing the stuff and i
didn't know how to get it and then i'm
i'm worried because i haven't got the
money and when somebody just takes that
little bit of time to just give you
five minutes and just give you a bit of
effort and just give you a bit of
support
it's so rewarding to see the results of
that you know and
and i give my time to people because i
know that they respect it i know they
value it and i know that
because they've paid for the economy
exactly but even even
people that come on um yeah samuel 365
oh yeah at any level of the training
yeah you know if they've paid for
the crash course people that spend 10
hours at the crash course yes yeah
that's true
they've paid for it because they took
the trip that's it they value the time
and effort they put into it
yeah whether it be from a time
perspective or a money perspective and
they value what they've put into it
yeah so then then i'll invest some time
in that backwards and give back the same
way somebody did to me
a long time ago yeah and that's the
thing if peop i get messages on
instagram and stuff people saying to me
oh sammy give me a house
you know oh if you if you're that rich
just give me a grand and it's like
i can give you a fish or i can teach you
to fish and and um
with the eviction in 2019 you won it
i then pulled you back in the following
year i actually pulled loads of people
from the eviction back and i pulled
james in
ricky and hannah in um to come back to
give
and you came back on to the eviction in
2020 which was actually only last
a month or so ago what happened it was
amazing to be part of that process
because
i was having flashbacks of painting
houses and wanting to strangle john ray
bold
um but it was i remember the
relationships i built throughout that
process
and you know i also get the frustrations
of alistair and russell when we were
there
and even yourself because when you're
you're driving around with these people
and you're
just just do this and you're trying not
to give too much support and
too much help you're trying not to do it
for them and you're thinking
you're missing that over there and i can
see that you're missing it why can't
you see it yeah but they have to go
through that growth
like you said they have to fail to grow
yeah you know and
seeing the journeys of people throughout
the eviction you know lawton
evans you know david they're absolutely
amazing and it was
it was i'm so glad that i got to be part
of their journeys because now that they
reach out to me and ask questions
and you know and i've built friends with
them and it's great to see
their journeys in the future yeah and
you know what's really funny when we do
the eviction 2021
no doubt some of the even people like
faz and jamal
have become financially free already
they'll be they'll be coming back to
support and give back so
and like hendrick you know like
when he got evicted the devastation on
his heart because i was sat in the
bordering with you i could see it and i
felt it because i knew what it was like
being in that boardroom and to feel that
pain
but all he's done is that's fueled his
fire you know
within a week he was getting keys for
rent to service accommodation apartments
yeah
that's amazing and and that is that just
goes to show that
he wasn't quitting like he said and he
was gonna put the effort in so you know
i really commend people like that
what would you say to someone that was
weighing up booking onto the crash
course whether it be the property
investors crash course virtual or coming
down physically obviously it's
similar content what would you say to
someone who's thinking about it i think
if somebody's thinking about it then
somebody has a hunger for property or
somebody has a desire to get into
property
and you're either in it or you're not
and if you want to get into property and
you're serious about doing it you need
to invest your time
you need to invest your money whether it
be into education or into property you
need to
invest yeah so if you are serious and
about doing it then book onto the crash
course yeah but if it's a whim then it's
not for you and
you know but serious people the crash
course is a great place to start to
network
and like everybody says it all starts at
the crash course yeah and as well
it's got to burn it's got to be if
you've got no money
and you're in a a place whereby you
can't just invest lots of money into
property
you've got to work hard and you've got
to roll your sleeves up and it's got to
burn
you know someone said to me samuel how
do you stay so motivated all the time
and i said because there's a fire
and if you've not got that desire to
want to succeed
i mean and sometimes you've got to hit
rock bar i mean
2020 has been so tough for me and i've
never hustled so hard in my entire life
good
you know and that's because
you know the goals change all the time
and but that fire and that burning never
goes away it
always stays there yeah and also i
remember when we first met like
um you know your bath your bath story
you know i mean
tell me tell me what happened i mean
i've not heard i've not heard you say
it's a long time
so back when we first met like you you
know you like like you said i've
struggled a lot with mental health you
know
i still do now you know and i have
struggled so long with it throughout the
years
and you know when i first when i first
met you i literally had nothing you know
my my partner had left me i was stuck in
this house that i couldn't really afford
to run on my
own and then i got told i was
potentially going to be made redundant
as well
and you know it was tough and then
things started breaking in the house and
i didn't have the money to fix them
and you know like i said to you that the
rock bottom moment for me and
this was the moment that made me pick
the phone up to my brother and made me
ring him and say i need to get out this
hole i need to know what's next
because if i don't know what's next
there isn't going to be a next
you know that's a scary thought and i
was sat in my bathtub and
the the thought is i was filling up
a bucket with hot water from the kettle
because i had no hot water in my house
no heating
and i was bathing myself with this
bucket and
i remember to the day and this is the
fuel that keeps me going sitting there
thinking
is this really it you know have i worked
my whole life
for this and i get glimpses of of things
that come back from that
and you know obviously you will know
in 2020 i lost my dad
and then my my dad was a great person he
was a
you know he was a complete rock and he
supported me the whole way through my
life
and then all that's left is
paperwork you know all that's left is
closing accounts you know and there's
that that's it that's all his life
amounts to is the memories that we've
got with him
and i don't want to leave that you know
i don't want to leave that for my
daughter i don't want to leave that for
my mum from my partner i want to leave a
legacy
and that is what drives me through all
the tough stuff every single day
yeah and that is what will drive me in
2021 and
2022 and so on and how old is your
little girl
so she's she's just about to turn four
months that is on a very recent she is
the best thing that ever happened to me
that was your first it's my first year
massive congratulations thank you thank
you and as well
as as a family man as a friend as a
person
you know not only have you done well in
property make lots of money now which is
great
but for me there's nothing more
rewarding than seeing somebody like you
winning because you deserve
every bit of success that you've got and
also i know that when you started
doing bio-refurbishing finance deals and
i called you out on it because you told
me that you had
your reason for doing it was because you
wanted to provide good accommodation for
people
you remember you told me that yeah and
you said that i still do that my
my you know my reason for doing by my
reasons for doing any property strategy
is because
all of these crappy landlords that are
out there yeah i will make my properties
better and make them go out of business
because nobody wants to rent their
properties
because i have been in that crappy
rental property with the single pane
windows and the mold on the walls
you know so everything we do is about
providing great accommodation
you know at every single level it's
about providing great accommodation for
people
yeah and you told me that and you were
like i'm doing this because i want to be
able to provide
good accommodation for people because
i've lived in this bad accommodation i
was like
no no you just want to make money you'd
want to make money and you were like no
serious and
i think and i was kind of testing you a
little bit but as we got to know each
other over the years i've seen that
actually no your
your heart is to help people it's just
it's to live a good life but also to
leave a legacy
um for your family to help those around
you and you do that every day you help
everybody that you talk to is encouraged
is blessed is inspired
so um you know i just want to as well
thank you i know i know i kind of
helped you get started and i've mentored
you and stuff but i want to thank you
because of everything you've given back
to the academy everything you've given
back to to me into the business
you know i really appreciate and i know
um i know 2020 came with its ups and
cameras downs
but it's just so good to see you winning
so um thank you so much
and and honestly guys if you're thinking
of coming down to the property investors
crash course this is real
like this is legit right anthony this is
this is legit
so i'll leave a link in the description
below
come on down this is people aren't
talking about this
you won't hear about these types of
methods in school
you don't read about them in the books
but this is real
is it easy no you're gonna have to put
hard work in is it possible
yes so i hope to see you at the property
investors crash course it's free
it's virtual it's on me so i'll leave a
link in the description
thanks so much i hope you enjoyed
listening to anthony's story if you want
to see more winners wednesday stories
every wednesday at 7 pm i interview
somebody
maybe they're not quite as impressive as
anthony but i interview somebody
who's had their life changed through the
exact same training that you can receive
as well
for free that anthony came on so
check them out right here there's a
whole list over 100 of these stories
a lot of people copy me on youtube but
they don't copy that also subscribe
right here to the channel and i look
forward to seeing you at the property
investors crash course get booked on
thanks for watching